hı Hello herkese Tonguç akademi'den
Merhaba arkadaşlar bugün Almanca'da
başımızın belası olan bir konuyla
karşınızdayım artık eldard estiği Peki
bu artık erleri nasıl kullanıyoruz hazır
saat dersimize başlayalım
[Müzik]
Ben 10 lira tema hemen Ben şuradan
kalemimi alıyorum onun sırtıma konumuz
Almanca'da bulunan 3 adet belirli artık
elde
Erdi ve Das dediğimde ve bu artık
ellerin nerede ve nasıl kullanacağını bu
dersimizde tamamıyla öğreneceğiz alırsak
Son sürat devam ediyoruz Almanca'da her
ismin ya da kelimenin bir cinsiyeti
vardır ve artık Eller bu belirlenen
cinsiyetlere göre kelimenin önüne
gelerek onları tanımlarlar yani onları
aslında betimler Peki bu cinsiyetler
biyolojik cinsiyetler mi Hayır
dilbilgisi kurallarına göre oluşturulan
cinsiyetler yani biyolojik cinsiyet
değil Peki değer için Eril kullanıyorum
yani bir erkekten bahsediyorum diye için
dişi diyorum yani bir kadından
bahsediyorum ders içini seni Ben diyorum
yani nötr varlıklardan ya da cansız
varlıklardan bahsediyorum Almanca'da her
kelimenin önüne derdi das Artık
yerlerinden biri eklemem gerekiyor ama
bir sürü kelime var Ben bu kelimeleri
nasıl ayırt edeceğim de hangisi Eril
hangisi dişin hangisi nötr diye
seçeceğim ediyorsanız cevabı bu videoda
hemen Son sürat devam ediyoruz belirli
tanımlıklar ne diyoruz karşılığında
belirli
artikeller Peki ilk artık elimiz olan
Derneği için kullanıyordu keril
cinsiyetleri için yani erkekler için
kullanıyorduk Peki ben kelimeleri ayırt
edebilmem için belli başlı kurallarım
var Evet bu kuralları ezberlemem biraz
zor O yüzden her öğrendiğim yeni
kelimeyi artık ile birlikte öğrenmem
gerekiyor biyolojik cinsiyeti erkek olan
tüm kelimelerin artikeli der olur Derman
adam de yaz on erkek evli o erkek çocuk
diyebiliriz diyaf atababa değer guru
sıfata büyükbaba Yani aslında burada
bahsettiğimiz biyolojik cinsiyet Peki
dilbilgisel cinsiyete geldiğimizde
yönler Dağlar hava durumu araba
markaları para birimleri ve soneki en
ile biten kelimelerin hepsi değer artık
ele alıyor arkadaşlar devreye giren
yağmurda tablet Şimşek de Austin Doğu de
Ağrı Ağrı Dağı ya da de a Uludağ
diyebiliriz Uludağ'da diğer bir Ev ve
araba markalarından olan BMW markasında
ne yapıyorum araba markalarında der
artık elini kullanıyorum peki para
birimleri dedim hemen buraya bir para
birimi ekliyorum diğer Oo Euro Ama tabii
ki istislam var nerede istislam lirayı
söyler kendi lira Evet buradaki bahset
ve biyolojik cinsiyet değil dilbilgisel
cinsiyet hemen devam edelim günün
bölümleri Günler aylar ve mevsimler de
ben der Artık yeni kullanıyorum de
Morgan sabah defa mi tak öğleden önce
Derya Nova Ocak de winta yaz bazı
içeceklerde de örneğin de affın zapt
elma suyu de kafi kahve diyeti çay Yani
daha çok meyve suyu ve bitkisel ve
kahvelerde Ben değer artıkelli
kullanıyorum mesleklerde ve sonu er ile
biten kelimeler de Yani aslında
erkeklerin yaptığı mesleklerde Bender
Artık yeni kullanıyorum diğer calla
garson demek Ama ben de erken na
dediğimde garsonun erkek olduğunu
anlıyorum değerli ha öğretmen yine
öğretmenin erkek olduğunu anlıyorum
diğer study o öğrenci ama nerede öğrenci
bir üniversite öğrencisi üniversite
öğrencisi Deko aşçı yine erkek olduğunu
anlıyorum değer
restan volt Avukat Evet tüm bu
taktikleri bildikten sonra artık değer
artık ile bizim için çocuk oyuncağı sonu
ilk Eğer
Linux rest Esma os eş ile biten
kelimelerin her zaman artıkelli değer
olur de tepeş halı sonunda iş var hemen
bakıyorum evet der artık gibi kullanmam
gerekiyor değer Hong iş balder
schmetterling kelebek değer idealism mor
idealizm ne yapıyorum ismi Evet var Ne
yapmam gerekiyor der artikeli kullanmam
gerekiyor Bunu biliyorum de motor motor
diğer istediğimde dedi ritim muz hemen
bakıyorum ismos ya da mu her gördüğümde
Bender Artık yeni kullanıyorum diğer
kompyutera
bilgisayarda Red na sonundaki eve R
harflerinden Ben bahsettiğim kişinin
erkek olduğunu ve aynı zamanda der artık
elinden de bahsettiğim kişinin erkek
olduğunu anlıyorum Son sürat devam
ediyoruz ve diğer kendine geldik ne
demiştik diğer dikeni için dişil
varlıklar için kullanılıyor Yani daha
çok kadınlarda kullanılıyor biyolojik
cinsiyeti kadın olanlar ve kadınların
yaptığı meslekler de beğendiği artık
elini kullanıyorum defro kadın di tente
teyze ya da hala anlamına geliyor diş
Vestel kızkardeş dillerin öğretmen ne
yapıyorum sonundaki iğne takısına
bakıyorum ve başındaki artık ele
bakıyorum kadın bir öğretmenden
bahsediyorum diye şu Dentin öğrenci ama
nasıl bir o kadın ve öğrenci değil şu
Dentin bir kadından bahsediyorum
biyolojik cinsiyetten bahsediyorum Peki
Metin genç kız demek buradaki istisna
nedir Normalde benim biyolojik cinsiyeti
kadın olduğu için ne yapmam gerekiyor
diğer Canon getirmem gerekiyor ama tabii
ki burada bir istisna var Ders ne için
genç kız isimlerin çoğu hallerinde Biz
her zaman değil kullanırız ve buna pulur
Aldi deriz yani çoğul değil pleural
deyip biten teyzeler Dime na adamlardi
fravun kadınlar düştü ile sandalyeler
peki dimen aa üzere iki nokta gördüm
nasıl okuyorum mannered İyi okumuyorum
2E gibi okuyorum dinlen abla Evet isim
olarak kullanılan sayılar Nur dediğimde
Tabii ki beni anlarlar Ama artık hem de
bilsem kötü Olmaz dinle oldu Sıfır
designed the Hun 400g Ama genel olarak
meyve çiçek ve ağaç isimlerinde her
zaman diğer kendini kullanıyorum değil
Ayşe
meşedibi yanı armut drowze Gül dizer o
zaman nilüfer çiçeği diz onun blume
ayçiçeği dipel mi Palmiye ya da palmiye
ağacı Evet peki başka taktikler imiz var
mı Tabii ki var sunu ete ay HYT kayıt
unogs aftin ile biten kelimeler her
zaman diğer artık eline alır di taşı e
gördüğünüz gibi çanta din aht gece Dibek
Eray bu arada eve iyi yan yana
gördüğümde ay diye okuyorum ay highet
kayıt gibi Dibek Eray fırın Dimes keray
Kasap dişu lerin kız Az önce ama nasıl
bir kız öğrenci biliyor musunuz ilkokul
ya da lisede ki bir öğrenciden
bahsediyorsa ben o zaman de şu lerin
kullanıyorum ilkokul veya lisede okuyan
bir kız öğrenciden bahsediyor Sam Ben
diş şu lerin kelimesini kullanıyorum
Eğer ki üniversitede okuyan bir kız
öğrenciden bahsediyor samdi studenten
kelimesini kullanıyorum ilk Ben şu
Dentin Ben öğrenciyim ama nasıl bir
öğrenciyim üniversitede okuyan bir
öğrenciyim defro indin kız arkadaş
sonundaki eklere dikkat ediyoruz di
krankheit hastalık Hatta şöyle kalemimi
değiştireyim yeşil olayım ki daha çok
dikkat çeksin Tek izin tayt sağlık Hayat
gördüm Ne yapıyorum Diyor artık elimi
getiriyorum dikil aydog kıyafet Düt Sait
on gazetede wissenschaft bilimci
freundschaft arkadaşlık Diva bunu ve
İslam Ben buradaki ekleri bildiğim zaman
gördüğüm kelimelerin artık eline tahmin
edebilirim Evet diğer tikel ile ilgili
taktiklerini öğrendiğimize göre Son
sürat devam ediyoruz diğer dillerden
Almanca geçen kelimelerin son ekleri
aiona de Age and
x tur olan yabancı asıllı kelimelerin
isimlerin artık ile her zaman di olur
diliran iradi marmeladı reçel sonundaki
adı ekimiz hemen bakıyoruz Evet kontrol
ediyoruz doğru diğer Canon gelmesi
gerekiyor diye tajık at degajı garajd
ikon Squad sonuç Tito el atı tuvalet
gördüğünüz gibi çoğu kelime yabancı
asıllı kelime Hatta Türkçede
kullanıyoruz din Muzik müzik politik
politika din atasyon millet ya da köken
diyebiliriz bu istasyon istasyon dik
ovalit et kalitedir üniverdi TED
üniversite diri al it it gerçek Dina
tuhaf Doğa dik uğultu a kültür ben bu
ekleri bildiğim dedi artık Senin
geleceğini Önceden tahmin edebilirim
Evet Son sürat devam ediyoruz sıkı
tutunun ve karşınızda Das artikeli
canlıların yavrularında Ben her zaman
Das artikeli kullanmam gerekiyor Das
beybi Das kind aslam Kuzuda küken civciv
küçük civcivler böyle fiil veya
sıfatlardan türetilen İsimlerde da sesın
yemek Das lafın uykuda Sayın Crown
alışveriş da slibinin yaşam dediğimde
ben yine da Sart kendini kullanıyorum
renklerde Das geld Şubat Evet renkleri
tek başına da kullanabilirim gelip svat
grup ve Ama artık elinde Bilmem işime
yarar metallerde ise degas Gold altın
gaz Aydın Demir da scopa bakır ve son
olarak da platin platin Şen Wella
inekleri almancadaki küçültme ekleridir
yani bir şey böyle küçük göstermek tatlı
göstermek için Almanca'da biz bu ekleri
kelimemiz in sonuna getiririz dasma için
kız çocuk ya da genç kız da diyebiliriz
Das biçin resimci börek küçük bir
resimci qdas pro-line evlenmemiş genç
kadın ya da genç kız diyebiliriz yine
Das bölümü şençiçek çek Das
hoşin evcik ya da kulübe daha anlamlı
olacaktır burada Evet peki Das
artikelinin sonuna gelen başka ekler yok
mu Tabii ki var kelime mizin Sonu'nu
ekledi getiriyoruz ve da Sart Canon
geleceğini öğreniyoruz hemen bakalım O
ek lerimize sonu um şu an EST Omen tveo
ile biten kelimeler Das artikeli alır
ders muzeum müze dustan throw Merkez da
selam hepiniz tecrübe da Sg hepiniz
sonuç çok benziyor kelimelerde mi
Aslında Das dağıtım tarih Das instrument
enstrüman Das dokumed belge Das Auto
araba Das radyo radyo daskin o sinema
gördüğünüz gibi sonundaki eklere
bakıyorum Diyelim ki kilo sinema
kelimesi aklıma artıkelli gelmedi ama o
sonuna o ekini ekleyeceğim aklımda ne
yapıyorum bildiğim için o ekine ile
kullanılıyordu hangi artık kendi
kullanılıyordu gaz artık eliyle ve hemen
daskin o olarak ben aklımda tutuyorum
Evet dersimizin sonuna geldik hemen son
sürat ödülü sorumuza geçelim bu nascenti
artık geldiği Zafer Ota buradaki
kelimelerin artık yerleri sizce ne
dikkat etmemiz gereken noktalar neresi
sonuna gelenekler hangi ekte hangi artık
el geliyordu yorumlara hem artikeliyle
birlikte kelimeleri hem de anlamlarını
bırakırsanız çok mutlu olurum bakacağım
Kim doğru yapmış kim Artık yeni doğru
yazmış Bir sonraki derste görüşmek üzere
Kendinize iyi bakın
Çüş düz
[Müzik]
abone ol